she doesn't cry when she sees me so she
likes me
good night sweetheart well it's time to
go the 1987 comedy about three very
eligible bachelors caring for an
adorable infant melted our hearts and
became the highest grossing film of the
year here's the baby
at the time Ted Danson was doing cheers
and Tom Selleck was starring as Magnum
PI I can only say that you know we got
recognized from doing some work in
television and uh you know we got
pictures from it it's good for me it's
been great Steve Guttenberg was coming
off the hit Police Academy movies what I
think is neat about it is that it takes
three guys who you can really identify
with he puts him in a situation which is
totally foreign to them and see how they
react everything's fine
don't you worry the film was directed by
Star Trek's Mr Spock himself Leonard
Nimoy the three stars and the baby hit
it off from day one
[Music]
aren't we three sexy guys I mean look at
that in 1990 the trio reunited for the
sequel three men and a little lady all
these years later they are still hoping
for a third go-round I think three men
and a bride would be such a hit movie
Tom wants to do it Ted wants to do it if
they can do a good story and a good
script not just a comic book sequel I'm
I'm there
come on in the meantime the film is
getting a reboot starring Zac Efron who
recently broke the internet with his
spectacular New Look Zach told us he is
all for a cameo with the og3 what can
you tease for the fans I think are so
excited for this I wish there was more
to uh to tease we're just getting a new
like draft on it soon so I'm really
excited for that and could we get a
cameo
in the movie I sure hope so I'll work on
that I'll put in the good word with the
um the Big Wigs I'm gonna
is that is Daddy not Zack daddy or what
is it Daddy's a hot dad
is it oh wow
all right I'll take that one
[Music]